Welcome. It's cohort one meeting,
17 already. And it's September 23,
2022. We're having our first discussion
of chapter seven in the textbook.
Well, we have many ways to
go. We have questions on chapter seven
that people have been adding.
We also have some summaries
and overviews and can walk through the
text directly. But first, does anyone
want to just raise their hand or unmute
and give any thought that they had on
chapter seven, their experience reading
it, their understanding of where it's
situated in the textbook overall, what
was in it, or what was not in it, et
cetera?
Okay, well,
open again. Please raise your hands or
write in the chat if you want to address
anything at any point. I want to open
by acknowledging a lot of the
contributions Ali made and in
some conversations that he and I had
earlier this week that I believe all of
you cohort wanderers will find
interesting. But first,
let's just start with this quotation.
We're going to start with the opening
quotation of the chapter. Then I'm going
to surface some discussions with Ali,
and then we're going to go into some
details of the chapter. So the quote is,
What I cannot create, I do not
understand by RF. So what
does anyone think about that quotation?
Or what does it mean in this context?
Um.
I think I mean,
it's more applicable.
Applicable? Applicable.
The more complex. The thing
is that you're trying to build. But what
priors or what way could your Generative
Model create an accurate prediction
of the operation of something or the
underlying dynamics of something if you
do not kind of step by step generate
the affordance, take the actions that
generate those affordances, I don't see
any causal path to doing that.
You would have to step through it
necessarily, if it's computationally
complex.
So that's most things in the world.
But yeah, awesome.
It's like this is the low road answer.
Like, how can the Generative Model have
anything like understanding without
generating? You can't just have it on
the shelf. And then someone has added
a mild answer. We can't
have understanding just
through mental envisioning that
the algorithms need to be implemented
for a learner's journey. And then
this is also an even deeper or stronger
point, which Friston
and others have been working on for a
long time, which is like it's sentient
artifacts in the world that
will be the realization of active
inference. It's not just like some nice
derivations. Brock and anyone else.
I was just going to add something about
hidden states. There again, coming back
to computational complexity, but there's
things now that we're starting to build
that we don't really 100% understand all
of the dynamics of what is or just in
general. We invent things that we don't
completely understand first. And then
based on the observational, based on the
evidence that we observe, that it is
consistently exhibiting some behavior
that directs our attention that directs
where our generative model pursues
more observations. But we're
definitely getting towards a point where
that's kind of no longer going to be
possible in the way that we usually try
to use math to just shortcut stuff,
where the operation of the dynamics of
the things that we're going to build are
necessarily going to be the proof.
Their existence will be their own proof.
Awesome. Okay, so just fun starting
quotation upload. That one for sure,
though there's some detailed things
about the
examples and
some of these I've been working on.
Everyone is welcome for every chapter to
be contributing on these pages. Like
kind of just trying to overview what
these examples are because a chapter,
it states it up front, yet I missed it
the first several times reading. It like
these illustrated models of every color
in the rainbow are the section titles,
and those are the functionalities that
are getting layered in sometimes
building on the same model. Like there's
like Team A's version one and then
there's Team A's version two. Other
times it's switching between models or
showing two different models that
illustrate the same cognitive
functionality. Other times the
simulation outputs are shown, other
times they're not. So there's like a lot
of heterogeneity in the observations
in this chapter, but it really wasn't
until I saw that these first
paragraph words were the section titles
that it made more sense how the chapter
was being laid out. So that's just kind
of one note.
Ali, do you want to raise any thoughts
or describe a little bit about our
discussion on how we're going to move
forward on the equations?
Okay. If you unmute, then go for it.
Otherwise okay.
Yes. No, Mike. Thank you. Ellie. All
good. So we were
discussing how there are several layers.
As with other scriptural traditions,
there's levels of readings. So there's
a level of reading that is even
more granular or below where we've been
currently targeting. Like, here's
equation 25, there's a reading
for accessibility and understanding that
would potentially be like F open square
bracket, q comma y closed bracket equals
negative sign expectation over Q, open
parentheses, et cetera. So it's like the
reading of the notation.
Then the notation can be substituted
for terms in the active ontology, which
is like the level that's being described
here, but this is not to be seen here.
This is the level where notation could
be aligned across papers because their
notational reading would be different,
but then they might be referring to the
same exact composition of the active
ontology. Then once the
ontology definition has been squared,
the terms could be condensed into
meaningful units like accuracy,
complexity, risk, expected risk
that gives symbolic in the more
conversational sense rather than in the
notational sense. And then that's
where memes and themes and rhetoric
around what active inference formalisms
say start to arise.
And then there's the consequences of
changes in relationships within and
outside the formalism because it's kind
of like there's this larger structure
for like a POMDP and changing one
variable. If you're only looking at one
view or one kind of sub formalism,
turn it up to eleven yet that might
influence other variables that aren't
part of that formalism itself. And so
this is like a very open question that
touches on everything from the
implications of changes to relationships
that aren't formally specified. For
example, the Bayes graph, the edges
reflect a certain type of relationship
as we've explored, but changes from
one can propagate throughout a whole
system, potentially in nonlinear ways.
So it's always going to be this kind of
open area.
How changes,
including counterfactuals about the
formalism, what if risk were situated
this way instead of that way? Or how
does that relate in this case? So this
is kind of an open one. Again, people
please update it and modify it.
But some of these equations which
we'll get to. So we'll come to why we
had that conversation in a 7.8 later.
But that was like one really interesting
conversation. And then
there was one other okay,
then just to kind of jump into a chapter
seven topic but also kind
of reframe our learning journey
as we're all working through this for
the first time in the textbook group.
So they wrote,
um,
this choice in the teammates and then
Eric or anyone else. I know that you had
some questions on the teammates, or we
can go to the earlier examples, but this
choice of what to do do you seek out the
informative queue and then go to the arm
that you've now reduced your uncertainty
about where the reward is? So do you
take an epistemic action and then have a
better chance of making the
pragmatically good choice or do you just
go and make the pragmatic choice? Do you
take one step up or do you take one step
back for two steps up? It speaks to the
exploration exploitation dilemma in
psychology and machine learning. A
dilemma that's resolved under active
inference. So we were just cracking up
because first
a low familiarity learner might not know
what these terms are or like why it's
relevant to even talk about this
situation.
Familiarity might look like knowing
metaphors, examples, intuition, some
relevant citations or historical
anecdotes about this.
The understanding in terms of what the
active inference formalism says about
this, if it's resolved under active
inference then understanding that
resolution is about the basis and
then from understanding there could be
like further developments and
applications and then we'll
come to this. But what was making us
laugh was surely there are
parameterizations in which the rat and
the teammates always does one thing
or always does the other. So it's
not that the explore exploit trade off
is simply resolved under active
inference even though people commonly
point to things like the ability to
rapidly switch between exploratory and
exploitative behavioral policies because
there's parameterization of that model
and structure learning including that
that has to be accomplished such that
the model can be in a kind of critical
point where it behaves adaptively and
thus in a situation manages the explore
exploit tension under
certain constraints. But how could it be
said that active inference resolves that
dilemma? So maybe to whomever
wrote this one? What is happening? Yes,
please. Eric, classical Eric writing
here. So what about this?
Yeah, I'm kind of the heckler at the
garden party here. You can see in most
of my comments and questions but
yeah, maybe it's just best to I mean
it's maybe better read than spoken but
yeah, I don't see this as a valid claim
that they well, first of all,
I don't know why they call it a dilemma
for psychology. It's a trade off. It's
been understood for years and there's
ways of formalizing it and you solve it
through optimization. It might be a
dilemma for a creature because they
don't know what they should do, but
that's not a dilemma for the field.
And then I guess the other paragraph is
I don't see that they offer any
resolution. All they do is they put it
into the same they use a common
language, free energy. They put
exploration and exploitation into the
same equation and call it with this
information based term called free
energy which is perfectly valid. That's
great. But that doesn't resolve the
problem because as you pointed out,
you've got parameters and the
designer or somebody has to figure out
what those relative weights are, the
parameters are. And so
you really haven't advanced anything
fundamentally, simply by using this
free energy way of expressing what the
trade off is as opposed to some
arbitrary measure called energy or
preference or something like that. So I
just think that it doesn't help them
when they overclaim, which is my opinion
and you can convince me otherwise, I'm
open. But it seems to me it doesn't help
them by overstating their contribution
to resolving
exploration versus exploitation.
Yes, very insightful. I actually totally
agree. I purposely tried to not mention
it as a dilemma either. I think
tensions, trade offs, these are all
valid but that's kind of micro
linguistic and a more serious issue is
that claims that do crystallized
out from the text and things that people
can copy and paste and quote if this
were a courtroom scenario did you
say that active inference resolves
exploration exploitation? The answer has
to be yes, it was claimed in the book.
Could somebody contextualize that like
it's providing a first principles way
where there are tunable or learnable or
parameter sweepable features of models
that sit at a really well positioned
intersection of human interpretability
and manifolds of relevant model
variation? Yes, in an extremely
charitable reading one could kind of
bring this from coming off over the edge
back onto the table.
That would also make active
inference less surprising and less
realistically hyperbolic and be
part of this process of seeing
the evidence in the realization,
not in the kind of ironic
like we have a different partitioning of
a statistical variable value. So nice
points Brock.
I guess I wanted to agree with
that and then also maybe play a little
devil's advocate,
it's all information so solved
just because it's been formulated or
renamed to something pragmatic value,
epistemic value, it doesn't seem like
that resolves it or something.
I'm wondering if the reading of that
though could be not that there
is still a trade off but that the
dilemma. Is that what they're talking
about is that the trade off, like when
do you explore or when do you exploit?
Not that there is a trade off but that
is this last sentence
and a half here. The resolution
stems from the minimization of free
energy. Is that whether you
would seek pragmatic value or
epistemic value is conditioned on
which your model believes to be
the free energy minimizing choice
though you still have the dilemma, so to
speak, or the trade off. But which side
of the trade off you take is
maybe resolved.
By a. Generative model here or not, I
don't know. Thanks Brock.
I think the field is set for a
situational resolution that may be as
good or maybe better than other ways
that it's been addressed but it
comes down to the exact numbers that are
chosen. So like in the example of the
teammates. So we
can look at for example this zero
six and negative six.
What if it was negative 3000 and
positive 3000? And so this came up in
the live stream 45 with Ryan Smith on
the folk psychology where the intensity
of the preference was represented. And
so if the preference is so we prefer
having more food, is that
going to be 1000 versus zero? Because if
so even the scantest probability of
achieving food will be pursued. In other
words, that model is going to be
parameterized way, way on one side and
it's going to exploit only or it's only
going to take locally greedy behavior.
Whereas if someone said well my behavior
for food is zero zero one then
maybe even the most obvious strategy
would not be undertaken because it's so
close to having a flat preference. Why
is zero one versus why is 3000 too high
and zero one too low? Well it has to do
with the ratios and the interactions
of a lot of the parameters.
So it's not even going to be like well
my preference is three comma one.
That is going to be just like two
parameters being drawn out from a
potentially massive parameterization of
a model. And so preferences
just only speaking of preferences may be
very hard to compare across situations
because it's not like plus six for the
preference for food and negative six.
It doesn't have a semantic meaning in
the world. It's literally a model
parameterization. And so then
the question becomes how can this
framework or this way of having
of combining probabilistic inference and
energy based inference for strategic
decision making, how can those
parameters be tuned into a region of
subspace or manifold where the behavior
is flexible and adaptive? So I think the
stage is prepared for a first principles
resolution in
charitable reading. Sorry. Yes, please.
Yeah, I was just going to say Ali shared
this paper meta control of the
exploitation exploration exploitation.
It's in the nearby chat link. Nice.
But yeah, it's not that it solves it
like in some grand it eliminates
exploration exploitation or that it even
completely currently it's just
the affordance, I guess seems to be
there to explain which one
why. Like you're going through that
there's a preference heavy here or heavy
there and it's not that it's
base optimal, right? It's not that it
makes sense or it's adaptable or
anything like that necessarily, just
that there is some causal through line,
maybe. Yes. Eric yeah,
so I want to first read Ali's comment
here. The critical point to establish
is to define action selection
as a balance between maximalization of
expected reward and expected information
gain which are functionals of posterior
beliefs about latent states of the
world. So that touches on one
of the questions which I also wrote
comments on, which is about the team,
a's example in particular, and I
don't know if we'll have time, but we
may get to that one today.
But the questions specifically I want to
raise about this comment, or maybe I
guess this is a quote about there
being a balance between maximization of
expected reward versus expected
information gain. That's one way of
having a trade off. But you might look
for an agent that only
wants to maximize reward in the
long run, but in order to do that, that
entails information gain and that
therefore gives a motivation for why you
want to attend to the other term,
the information based learning
based term or knowledge refining a state
based term. But that's in the service of
the larger gain. And that's essentially
what a reinforcement learning tries
to do is say look, we're going to look
ahead so that the moves we take now will
bring us advantage in the future and
there's a time discounting and all that.
So that takes away the idea
of information as being a value in and
of itself, but it's only for a purpose.
I'll raise that specifically with regard
to the team. A's example in a different
question. Yeah,
thank you. The balance between
Pragmatic and Epistemic is the
optimization. So that is the question
and that is the critical point and
that's the situational balance that
modeling is going to be evolving around
it's like some situationally optimal
or preferable strategy around.
That is the point.
But pointing to the point is not the
resolution. Does active inference
provide us a natural language grounded
first principles approach? It may,
but that is also not dilemma
resolution. So onto some questions,
but these are really great points.
Okay, this is just an
example of a type of question that I
encourage people, especially if they're
going back to the earlier chapters or
just whenever they feel like making a
contribution of this kind. These are
like super helpful questions. Again,
the questions we write, some of them may
be included in really important
educational materials, not the least of
which many further textbook groups, but
potentially even far beyond that. So
what would you ask somebody to
understand their comprehension of the
materials? So I understand what are the
rows, columns and numbers in these
equations? And it even
says it in the text. It's the
probability of the next state. So the
next state is in the rows, and then the
current state is in the columns. And
this gets distributed across everything
so that the rows and columns sum to one
as any other transition probability
matrix would be expected to have.
So we don't need to discuss it unless
somebody wants to go into a little more
detail. But this is going to be at the
core of that third step of the recipe,
which is you might have the structural
form from the second step of the recipe
in chapter six. And then the next
step is to kind of specify or
instantiate, like in code,
what the dimensions are of
these matrices. This is just saying like
they are matrices. There's some prior
tensor matrix, some hidden state,
some transition matrix, some emission
matrix. And this is like the structure
step two of the recipe. Step three, how
many rows and columns. And as Yaakov
and others have been exploring, there's
the rows and columns of the analytical
representation with the equations.
And then there's how Pi MDP does
it, and there's how different
computational realizations do it.
Jacob, would you want to add anything
about the dimensionality of these
matrices? It could be interesting.
Yeah,
I can probably speak more to how Pyme DB
deals with the dimensionality, which
currently is probably adds
unnecessary redundancy to them.
Like if you're dealing with more complex
state space or rather more high
dimensional state space, and you have
different modalities that you want to
encode in these matrices because
you're then performing
matrix multiplications, you need to keep
the dimensions of the matrices in
those given modalities equal, at least
in time DP not in other methods
as far as I'm aware. But that means that
then you have dimensions within these
matrices that don't contain any
information. So say you have a
grid that you represent for the
likelihood mapping of observation and
state in physical world, but then you
have another type of observation,
like where is another agent located with
respect to you? Are they in a certain
direction? And that might be represented
by five observations,
say, like they're above, they're below,
they're to the right, to the left, or
not at all. Then you would
need to encode the observation in the
nine by nine matrix, but then you need
to replicate it five times because that
is the same for each of those relative
observations. But then when you want to
encode the likelihood mapping just for
the second type of observation. I'm
actually not entirely sure what that
would be, but I'm presuming it's going
to be like five by five, but then
replicated. Nine times or something like
that, just so the dimensionality
matches. Because then you're doing
inference over both modalities and
at least in prime DP, you're then
performing matrix multiplications
over both of them. Thank you.
Jakub. One way I'm kind of like
seeing that is there's the sparsity of
the graph. But then,
in Pym DP or in any given computational
implementation, the data structures,
including potentially, like, auxiliary
data constructs, may have a
dimensionality that reflects
potentially, at worst, a combination
of the dimensionality of other aspects
as part of even just a Temp file that
you didn't even exactly specify. There
might be some intermediates, stated or
unstated intermediates whose
dimensionality isn't merely
the dimensionality of the analytical
representation. It's a little bit
of a subtle implementational point. But
this is the mountain to climb, to
implement these kinds of models.
And also, just while we're on this
topic, I think it's one area where CAD
CAD is going to be very interesting to
explore in active block for its package,
because we also can imagine that the
execution order of certain operations,
even in a single agent setting, not just
the multi agent setting, is really
relevant. So there's that question.
All right, so figure 7.2. All right. So
the first example is about a musician
playing music.
We are not aware of this example being
used anywhere else. Like the citations
following those. This musical note type
representation is not shown. And
previously we kind of discussed how some
of these trace black and white images
are really ambiguous because
of being like, intersecting black lines.
And then, of course,
the empty square. Yes.
Can you say where those black lines come
from? You want to dive into that right
now? Yeah. Well,
okay. The upper
left, each black line, even though it
can be hard to trace them, I think
they're just being shown like
representationally. They're beliefs
about each note in the sequence at each
time step. So the time steps are on the
x axis and the
belief in terms of a probability are on
the y axis. So initially right. So
there's some there's some sort of and
this gets to another question that was
raised, but maybe this is time to talk
about it. There's some sort of engine,
some sort of differential equation
simulator or something running
underneath here right. That is not
discussed in the chapter, but that's
generating these belief curves. Yes.
It's related to some functions in
MATLAB. And I was just going to mention
that because my sense from the discrete
model would be you'd have five,
let's say, points on time zero, then
you'd have five points on time one.
So I thought, well, what is happening
with this kind of like little fractal
crash right here? How could you have a
continuously differentiable oscillating
type behavior when all
you're calculating analytically is just
12345? Then I
thought, is it meaning is, is the, are
the points actually at the midpoint?
And there's a differential equation
that's sort of like ribboning an action
perception loop through a discrete time
matrix. But then if
this is a function that's evaluatable at
every point, aren't we in a continuous
time setting? So wouldn't that
have to imply like a machinery for
unpacking a continuous time action
perception cycle from discrete time
specification? So I agree
very much. Yeah.
Good. My guess is what they do is
they've got the equations,
the free energy equations and the
parameters are these distributions.
Okay, what's your belief in these
different properties? And those
parameters evolve over time through a
differential equation because you turn
these things into a differential
equation and when you change state
something like, okay, now we've got
another note comes in, then that's
what's going to trigger the differential
equation to go in a different direction,
essentially. And that's why you've got
the five discrete kind of regimes
here or target points
that it kind of evolves to.
And then the next note comes in and now
the boundary conditions change,
essentially. So your differential
equation takes you in a different
direction. I recall that there's
something like you guys probably
discussed this more than I paid
attention, but there's some sort of
universal solver that they are
providing. So you just plug in your
matrices, your state equations,
your transition matrices, and then it'll
solve it all for you. And that may be
what this differential equation solver
is about. Do you think that sounds
right? Yes, I think whenever,
variously in the method sections and
supplemental sections of paper, they'll
say in the paper, we're only specifying
the generative model and the matrices
and then we use standard routines to
address it. Now, I don't think that has
the, it's not the pinnacle of
accessibility and reproducibility.
However, it does at least use standard
routines. But again, those are not
always specified in the paper, which is
an issue. So it'll be important to
regenerate examples within SPM and
then also to use some of these things
that we were discussing with the ability
to move between different languages,
but like VBX variational,
bayes X, I don't know what the X is
actually for.
It's one of the core functions.
It is actually doing the variational
inference in SPM. And again,
SPM is like this sort of like chimera
package because it arose from the
immediacies of needing to do
neuroimaging registration and dynamical
analysis that then broached into dynamic
causal modeling, random field theory
based statistical testing, permutation
testing all these areas that are not
themselves formally linked per se, but
rather useful as part of the toolkit of
a Neuroimaging researcher.
Then, just as we were a little bit
discussing like chapter two, and of
course, many times earlier in that
generalized Bayesian inferential
framework, hierarchical modeling,
including action, is actually not the
hardest thing. Yes,
implementing action is one thing, but
treating action selection as inference,
planning as inference, it has some
challenges that arise relative to just
doing time series anticipation,
but then those functions became compiled
into SPM in a limited capacity.
So again, they go through some of this.
But I think it's a key issue. We'll
definitely look forward to what the free
energy gradients are,
but where the
continuous nature of these curves and
why? There are the numbers that there
are 1234-5678,
910. Now there's five notes.
Ten is two times five.
There's a little bit more that needs to
be fleshed out there.
And then one question that was like,
again, somewhere between testing our
comprehension and being clear about what
we're doing here, and in this ambiguity,
we can ask it without any bias,
the negative free energy gradients. I e
prediction errors. What is
a prediction error? A free energy
calculation. Well, ignore gradient
for a second. Free energy calculations
are not prediction errors. Prediction
errors are observations minus
expectations. So this is like some
finite value in the state space of what
is being measured. Free energy is not
that it references potentially those
variables, but it does things that we
know about, like KL divergences and
such. Okay, so free energy is not
prediction error. And that's a huge
difference between, for example, a
predictive processing framework and
a free energy hierarchical predictive
architecture. Eric but they're
saying the gradient and free energy is a
prediction error. Exactly. So even if it
were that's, then that was the next
question, which was, what's the
difference between free energy and the
free energy gradients? Are we talking
about a landscape of
derivatives, of free energy energies,
or are we talking about what here?
Is it being described as a gradient, as
a landscape? And hence gradient ish
because it can be calculated over some
discrete, bi continuous state space.
It's like five skyscrapers that you
could have derivatives over in the
Y direction, but you couldn't take the
partial x. Or is it
truly or is it a
continuous landscape that just being
tethered to the discrete values in x?
But then again, that's that whole
continuous, discrete question. Or are
the values gradients,
which has an even more complex
interpretation. So we don't
have the answers on these, but it's
hard to understand how these figures
could have epistemic or pragmatic value
for learners or practitioners without
some of these questions being resolved.
All right, the first example,
this is just kind of from walking
through. So the first example was just
hidden Markov model hidden states
updating through time, Bayesian filter
column and filter. This is like just
standard signal processing in a Bayesian
framework. And we're.
Going to see a lot of echoes of the step
by step model stream one, they give an
even simpler example with static
perception, one step perception and then
go second to the dynamic case,
then introduce action pi policy and then
nuance policy through like uncertainty
and so on. So that's the first
inferential case they're then going to
head into decision making and planning
as inference. So we
see policy being introduced as a
variable that influences how
states change through time.
Does policy do that or does action do
that? In the one step limit,
policies are actions are affordances,
but Pi is specifically reserved for
sequences of actions. So is it that
sequences of actions like do that or is
this the actual base topology?
But nonetheless, that architecture
allows the evaluation of alternate
policies in terms of their relative
expect variational or expected free
energy, depending on whether a one step
policy is accomplishable with
variational free energy that's, like the
instantaneous move,
most consistent instantaneous maneuver
versus even one step in advance is going
to broach into this whole expected free
energy space we had
on 130. So there's
a really important discussion.
Bozaki is also very interesting
researcher neural rhythms and so on.
Factorization is a really important
topic and being able to distinguish like
neurologically what do we mean when we
talk about the what and the where
stream, the dorsal and the ventral
stream and critiques of it, et cetera.
But just what and where in the brain and
then in the factor graphs and
computationally because the unfactorized
models, if we're just doing the all by
all by all by all, those become
intractable very fast. And the
specification of the sparsity of the
model is one and the same in the
variational base framework as the
factorization of the model. So
factorization is like kind of focusing
your search efforts on manifolds where
you've constrained certain things to be
like linked or unlinked.
That is what motivates the structure
learning problem and the need
to have to
not be locked into factorization schemes
at a given level of analysis.
Okay, another just
question to explore.
Like here we have the top
half of figure 43. There's just one A
matrix.
So why are there two A matrices here?
Well, it's not an impossible question
and the symbols go a long way.
Here's the four locations that the
animal can be in starting position,
bottom position, left arm or right arm.
Then here are the
it's five on the X here because
that bottom could, could reveal an
R or reveal an L. In this case it
reveals an R and the
food is honestly there. And then this is
a second a matrix that is
describing how location is associated
with the food. None aversive
or positive. But this ties into the
earlier discussion. Like it might be all
one thing to say well it's four x five
and then four by three. But is this
actually a four x five by three.
I know it's not. Eric, what do you
think? Yeah, and they'd mentioned in
there it's a tensor also.
And the tensor means that you're
stacking this one,
this image against the version where the
reward is on the left side. So the
tensor is going to be four x eight
by two. So that makes sense for being
the tensor. So the state is another
layer on top of this. The hidden state
is another layer on top of that.
Yes,
section 73. So this would be a fun kind
of like PH d. Qualifying level.
Question just describe the whole team
ace every row, every column and every
value. Why is it that way?
So we're not going to type it out here,
but to understand that example
and what the B matrices are, and just
to have agility
and just identifying the differences
between these matrices numerically,
like pattern recognition, like, oh,
here there's two ones, here two zeros.
Here two zeros, here two ones, here one
and zero. These stay the same. And then
to be able to transpose that in your
understanding to what this means in
terms of transition frequencies,
every place where there's a difference,
it's a difference that makes a
difference. So being able to understand
what those are is about understanding
this example. And one can imagine,
especially if they're wanting to make an
application of active inference that's
more complex than this, four x four,
being fluent with how
these matrices are constructed, their
dimensionality, how differences in the
generative process are incorporated,
how differences in the generative model
are incorporated, all these different
features are important.
Yes, Eric, this is definitely very
important. Question agreed.
Like it, it looks extremely
neural, and these traces
come up all the time.
Similarly, here we have three discrete
time points starting going to
the Q, getting the L, and then going to
the left arm. But then what is
this? Step one and a half is the one,
all of these points. And then by two,
the uncertainty is resolved. The belief
about certain things goes to zero, the
belief about other things goes to one.
And this is just a pure interpolation.
But that is quite a specific
interpolation, including what appear to
be some like dopaminergic spikes or
something that are not reflected at
either of the time points. My guess is
that you've got three different blocks
there. So if you take the one as being
the width, one third of the way across
the two is another third and the three
is another third, then that switch there
that you see happens as soon as you
transition from the one to the two.
Yes, although still
there's even the graphical interpolation
interpolation. Question and
it's so easy to be like reading is it
just a quirk of the dashed line?
But are there two dashed lines?
And two dashed lines diverged in a
neural trace? But it's
kind of clear. These ones, the discrete
formulations are clearer.
Yeah. Okay. Are rats prone
to useless behavior? What do you think?
What useless behavior?
I wrote it out. Okay, this is good time
for today, but that's my most
provocative comment on this one. And
maybe we can save that for next week.
Okay, perfect. Let's pick up with this
one and any other questions.
Then we'll glance over the visual
cicade. Look at the learning example.
Consider the hierarchical example.
There's the maze. Then there's the
hierarchical example. Another nested.
Discrete meets neural continuous trace.
And then we end on Stefan's squared. So
thank you all. Have an excellent day.